[Music]
if you've been waiting for another look
at Mass Effect Andromeda you'll have
your patience rewarded tomorrow a new
cinematic trailer for the space RPG is
set to release and developer by our T's
that on Twitter today I'm Matt and this
is my favorite game spot news update on
the Citadel the teaser gives us a look
at a planet called habitat 7 which
character Alec Kreider speaks about
hopefully calling it a new earth if
we're lucky the Mass Effect twitter
account wrote a new galaxy awaits but no
one said it would welcome us Alec riders
the father of Andromeda is playable
character sarin Scott he's voiced by
Clancy Brown who's appeared in movies
like The Shawshank Redemption and
warcraft but is most recognizable for
his role as mr. Krabs in spongebob
squarepants Mass Effect Andromeda
releases on March 21st for ps4 xbox one
and pc EA and origin access members will
be able to play the game five days
before launch as part of a 10 hour trial
for more news on Bioware's upcoming
space adventure and the world of video
games stay tuned to gamespot